Joe Biden finally ends Bernie's red
dreams Biden gets aggressive with
Michigan voters and coronavirus
continues to haunt the country I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show the
Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your data is your business
protected and expressvpn calm /pan well
I know that right now you're thinking
yourself where did this sexy new voice
come from Ben Shapiro well the answer is
that it came from not sleeping for a
full week thanks to my child combined
with a fast day earlier this week so no
I'm not dying of coronavirus and no it
has not translated into this brand new
Barry white leg voice no indeed this is
just me being a little bit dried out so
hopefully my voice will be back to his
nasal self quite soon well the big news
last night Joe Biden has taken command
of the Democratic race he won four
states including Michigan in the
primaries last night and that puts an
end to Bernie Sanders and his red Dreams
which is great news for the country it
really is good news for the country
because it would have been very bad if
one of our major parties had circulated
around a human being who was a backer of
every communist regime known to man and
was basically a Soviet fellow-traveller
for 30 years before the Soviet Union
actually fell now that's a good thing I
know there are a lot of people in
Republican and conservative circles who
today are a little bit upset because
they feel like Bernie Sanders is more
beautiful than Joe Biden first of all I
think that Biden is eminently beatable
if Donald Trump cannot beat a geriatric
half senile half corrupt Joe Biden then
honestly that's on Trump I mean
seriously that's on Trump Joe Biden is
not a formidable candidate by any
stretch of the imagination if Trump is
unable to beat him that is on no one
except for President Trump there are a
lot of ways in which Hillary Clinton was
actually a more formidable candidate
then Joe Biden namely that Hillary
Clinton was capable of stringing a
sentence together from time to time and
was not apparently going senile or he
had other health problems but senility
was not one of them when I say that
Biden is senile by the way again this is
not ageism this is called using your
eyeballs it's called using your ears
when you watch Joe Biden talk the man
can barely hold it together for a
particular period of time and this is
why his campaign has already said he's
gonna start doing shorter speeches not
longer speeches look for him to barely
be on the campaign trail in long
drawn-out scenarios in fact there's
supposed to be a debate next week
supposed to take place between Joe Biden
and Bernie because Bernie isn't
dropping out he's gonna carry this thing
all the way to the convention so he can
try to parlay his delegates into some
sort of power inside the DNC well
they're supposed to basically have a
one-on-one debate for two hours no
audience now normally that would really
help Biden the reason there's no
audience of course is because of
coronavirus coronavirus concerns had but
Biden and Bernie cancelling rallies last
night Biden gave his victory speech to a
half-empty house essentially it was very
weird dynamic but they're supposed to
have a debate the way that debates
actually should be had in presidential
arenas which is no audience because who
the audience is really stacks the room
hey Bernie has benefited in debates
where a lot of his supporters are there
people shouting and screaming for
burning well when there is no actual
audience then who exactly is Bernie
gonna play to the commies across America
it's not gonna play the same way there
is one area though where Biden is
particularly vulnerable and that is that
Biden has been able to hide behind the
fact that there are 1,000 people on
stage up until now to talk for like a
grand total of 16 minutes well what
happens when he suddenly has to fill an
hour I mean Joe Biden can't fill a
paragraph without making some sort of
awful gaffe about his wife being his
sister or running for Senate or aka a
hour for teens or something so it's a
broader chance for the American public
to get to know the man who is not all
there so again do I deeply worried that
Trump cannot be Biden no so I think the
Biden is more formidable candidate than
Sanders yes because I think that
basically a rotted ham hock is a better
candidate than Bernie Sanders but with
all of that said Joe Biden did run away
last night with the vote and a lot of
that is a response directly to Bernie
Sanders some people are saying this was
due to coronavirus it really isn't due
to coronavirus it's due to the fact that
people saw Bernie Sanders as the
front-runner he started to be analyzed
as the front-runner everybody realized
he was an old commie and everybody ran
headlong from him coronavirus has
exacerbated this because people are
looking for a sense of safety for the
same reason that people buy bonds when
they feel volatility they're buying into
Joe Biden right now because when there's
volatility you run to chicken soup and
hot chocolate and all of the sort of
comfort foods Joe Biden is the comfort
food of American politics Joe Biden is
basically mashed potatoes I mean with as
much articulate 'no say as a bowl of
mashed potatoes he's just there right
he's there he's been there for a long
time he doesn't worry you too much
hidden toospicy he ain't gonna give you
some sort of disease
not gonna completely botch him his
handle things he's kind of there he's
there like mashed potatoes are there and
so people ran to Joe Biden as a sort of
sense of security in an ever changing
ever volatile world yeah we're gonna get
two more of these results won't get two
Biden's response and Bernie's response
in all of this because bernie is done
Bernie's not a thing anymore now does
that mean that for the future the
socialist agenda is done that doesn't
mean that at all as you will see the
demographic breakdown last night is very
bad for the moderates in the demo graph
in the Democratic Party for the future
going forward from here but we'll get to
that in just a moment first let's talk
about these are times when you just want
to feel safe in your home I mean you do
want to feel safe in your own not just
from things like coronavirus but
obviously from rising levels of crime
and a lot of America's major cities
there's a story just the other day about
rising street crime in New York here in
Los Angeles we've had serious cases of
rising crime the suburbs have become
less safe I know I'm able to look thanks
to ring I'm able to look at crimes in my
neighborhood and those crimes are
becoming ever more prevalent well this
is one of the reasons why you should
have ring devices on your home ring
gives you protection at every corner
helps you create custom affordable
security for your home ring video
doorbell let you answer the door and
check in on your home anytime from
anywhere rings full home security
systems they give you everything you
need to protect your family pets
property with rings outdoor security
cameras you can check in on every part
of your house so you will never miss a
moment ring helps you stay connected to
your home anywhere in the world
ring detects motion when people come
onto your property you receive
notifications on your phone tablet PC
see here speak to visitors in real time
from anywhere get peace of mind knowing
that your loved ones are safe we use
ring devices on our home you know I have
serious security concerns because of Who
I am but just generally because there
have been breaking some enterings in the
neighborhood lately you want ring
devices to make sure that your property
is safe no matter where you are on
planet earth get a special offer on the
ring welcome welcome kit when you go to
ring calm slash been the welcome kit
includes the ringing video doorbell to
and chime pro it's all you need to start
building custom security for your home
today just go to ring comm /ban that is
ring.com slash Bennigan's I couldn't
recommend them more highly ring.com
slash Ben so according to the New York
Times Joe Biden took command of the
Democratic presidential race in decisive
fashion on Tuesday marshalling a
powerful multiracial coalition in the
south and the Midwest that swept aside
senator Bernie Sanders and completed mr.
Biden's rapid transformation from a
sometimes fumbling underdog into his
party's likely nominee he's still
fumbling but now he's the party's likely
replicating the combination of voters
that delivered him broad victories we
could go on Super Tuesday Biden won
Michigan Missouri in Mississippi with
overwhelming support from African
Americans and with large margins among
suburban and rural white voters Biden
was also named the winner in Idaho
leaving little doubt by the end of the
night that Sanders had lost his recent
status as the progressive frontrunner in
a race to find for months by feuding and
factionalism on the moderate wing of the
Democratic Party
it wasn't until Wednesday morning that
Sanders picked up his first victory in
North Dakota
Washington remained too close to call
Biden demonstrated his successes on
Super Tuesday reflected more than
fleeting good fortune and that many
Democratic voters had rallied behind his
candid Eze candidacy in a last thing
enough way to erase his embarrassing
setbacks last month in Iowa and New
Hampshire so Joe Biden took to the stage
last night to announce that he wants the
support of the Bernie people he doesn't
want them running headlong from him good
luck with this Joe Biden so here was
Biden making his speech last night
I want to thank Bernie Sanders and his
supporters for their tireless energy and
their passion we share a common goal and
together we'll defeat Donald Trump with
the feet of the government were
regenerating a Democratic base the
Democratic Party the african-american
community high school educated folks
like the ones I grew up with in Claymont
not far from here in my old neighborhood
labor suburban women veterans
firefighters union members and so many
more he's baked he's barely alive but
that might be what voters are looking
for in an era where again you don't know
what's coming around the next bend and
president Trump is not exactly a beacon
of stability and neither is Bernie
Sanders Joe Biden is not a beacon of
stability in the sense that he might
topple over literally at any time but
you get the feeling that again people
who are barely not comatose generally do
not provide a serious threat to people's
feeling of sort of stability so there
was Joe Biden last night trying to reach
out to the Bernie Sanders people
Bernie's not gonna have any of that by
the way Bernie did not give a speech
last night when he gives a concession
speech it will likely be laced with all
sorts of references to how the
Democratic Party stepped in and stopped
him and again none of this is to say
that the future of the Democratic Party
is bright here even if Joe Biden were to
win the future of the Democratic Party
is with the insane radical progressive
agenda of Bernie Sanders
the the age gaps in the Michigan exit
polls are absolutely astonishing
hey this is according to the New York
Times if you were 18 to 24 which only
represented 7% of voters because young
people do not vote it's it's a puzzle
that Bernie never was able to solve
because no one has ever been able to
solve young voters not voting young
voters are very loud if they go to
rallies those people vote everybody else
doesn't vote this is one of the things
people don't understand about campus
politics I get asked about campus
politics a lot and people say well what
do college students think I said well
90% of them don't at least not about
politics right the 10% that do are
incredibly loud to get outsized
attention most college students are just
there to party and drink and screw and
and get out of there with a degree okay
that that's true for most young people
in general and so the idea that they're
sitting around like deeply ensconced in
the Bernie movement is just not true but
the ones who are involved are very very
radical 83% of voters in Michigan who
were between the ages of 18 and 24 voted
for Bernie 83 to 16 if you were between
the ages of 25 and 29 81% of those
voters in Michigan voted for Bernie
Sanders if you were between 30 and 39
62% of those voters voted for Bernie
Sanders just compared to just 34 who
voted for Joe Biden if you're between 40
and 49 Bernie's still on a slight
majority 51 to 45 of those voters it's
among the older demographics everybody
over the age of 50 that Biden just
cleaned up he between 50 and 64 he won
66% of the vote between 65 and death he
won 73 percent of the vote so that means
that Biden is still relying on this
older coalition of voters that doesn't
mean that he's gonna lose the election
because younger voters don't like him it
does mean that the future of the
Democratic Party looks a lot more like
Bernie Sanders and a lot and a lot less
like Joe Biden now with that said there
was a suburban surge of for Joe Biden
according to the Washington Post Biden's
victory in Michigan was powered by
landslide margins in the Detroit suburbs
places where turnout have been low in
the 2016 primary the same patterns
played out in other states voting on
Tuesday the suburbs of cities like st.
Louis Kansas City Memphis delivered big
margins for Biden bigger turnout than
four years ago DeSoto County which
contains the Mississippi Bay suburbs of
Memphis was one of the first areas to
report results four years ago just
seventy six hundred votes were cast for
all candidates in the Democratic Party
Hillary won 5,600 votes in 2000
eight the county cast slightly more than
10,000 votes in Tuesday's primary de
Soto cast 11,000 votes Biden 186 hundred
of them that tracks of what happened in
the state's 2018 and 2019 elections when
even as Democrats at law statewide races
they gained ground in suburbs and that
pattern was even more stark in Missouri
it was a swing state just 10 years ago
but now it has become a very red state
turnout may be flat from 2016 but in
Clay County which is the suburbs north
of Kansas City 29,000 votes were cast
with one precinct left report four years
ago only 23,000 votes were cast in the
county from then to now Sanders lost
ground winning 12,500 votes in that
contest with Clinton he came in below
11,000 votes on Tuesday an easy win for
Joe Biden the bottom line is that
moderate suburban nights are coming out
in droves now this may mean this may
mean bad news for president Trump this
is an area where President Trump is
particularly weak moderate suburban
Heights are the area that that Trump
really needs to make up some ground
right that's the area where he's sort of
basically the trade he made with Mitt
Romney was Mitt Romney won a lot of
these suburban people he won't want a
lot of suburban white women he won a lot
of college-educated white white men okay
and then Donald Trump traded a lot of
that for more rural support well what
from really should have done is built on
that we're all supporting then move back
into the suburbs the problem is that it
is exactly Trump's persona that is
off-putting to a lot of suburban women
particularly and Joe Biden again is a
sort of comfort food for a lot of these
folks okay so that's a problem for
President Trump but the bigger problem
for Joe Biden right now is how does he
unify the party because Bernie is not
gonna step back inside the party
remember bernie is not a party animal
Bernie does not really belong in the
Democratic Party he who spends his
entire life doing nothing and being a
gadfly has been his entire life now the
Democratic Party is picked and chosen
from Bernie's agenda right they picked
from the Bernie tree but that does not
mean that Bernie is in good standing
with the Democratic Party or anything
like that so bringing him back into the
fold Hillary was not able to bring
Bernie back into the fold in 2016 after
Bernie appeared to be the de facto
Democratic nominee just three weeks ago
him being rejected by an overwhelming
number of big-name Democratic donors as
well as a lot of big-name Democratic
politicians and the DNC you could see
the Bernie bros you're saying listen
we'll stay home we don't care as much as
Joe Biden is trying to reach out to the
Bernie Bros a lot
Earnie bros are not gonna be into this
and despite the attempts by the pod save
America Krabs said we got a rally to be
Trump I am NOT certain I really am not
certain that there are a lot of Bernie
Sanders voters who hate Trump more than
they hate the Democratic Party
establishment I think there may be a lot
of times there may be a lot of burning
voters who hate the Democratic
establishment more and want to punish
the Democratic establishment for
nominating Biden and so simply just
don't go to vote by the way the same
thing would have happened inside the
Republican Party if Trump had not been
given the nomination at the at the
convention if Trump had ended up being
skunked at the very last minute by a
coalition there's a good shot that a lot
of those Trump voters would have just
said listen we're not gonna show up
we don't want an especially if in am in
favor of Jeb right if it'd have been in
favor of somebody who is long considered
sort of the next in line there have been
a lot of Republican voters who had
walked away from the Republican Party
the same thing could be in the offing
and the Democrats are making a fairly
large-scale mistake if they refuse to
that they're sort of between a rock and
a hard place if they continue to let
Bernie Sanders on TV if they continue to
let Bernie Sanders debate Biden he's
just gonna damage Biden if they don't
bite then Bernie's gonna claim that
everything is wrong and that everything
is corrupt and that everything is foul
and then he's gonna drive his supporters
away from the Democratic Party so it's a
bit of a catch-22 for the Democrats they
either have to bet that most Bernie
voters are gonna come around
whatever Bernie says or they have to bet
that if they give Bernie another shot
they allow him a bunch of debates then
Bernie will somehow become a team player
at the last moment neither one of those
are particularly good bets again this is
one of the problems with humoring the
alligator until he eats you last forget
some more of this in just one second
first let us talk about a great pair of
ear buds okay so what kind of ear buds
you using a listen to the show using the
ones at the wires yeah aren't you right
I mean there were cheaper you've had
them for a while there's only one
problem one they're not very good
actually there are several problems one
they're not very good too you wrap them
up you put them in your pocket every
time you take them out again and now it
takes you 20 minutes in order to be able
to listen to what you want to listen to
you need wireless headphones the only
problem is those wireless earbuds that
you're looking at right now yeah those
ones they're really expensive and they
are one size fits all so they could fall
out of your ear this is why what you
need are a cons unlike some of your
other wireless options rake on earbuds
are stylish and discreet there no
dangling wires no stems that come in a
variety of colors most importantly they
come with a variety of fits they send
you a metal card on the metal Carter
of rubber pieces that fit in your ear in
particular ways you can find one that is
perfect for you ray Kahn has just
released their best model yet the e25
they have six hours of playtime seamless
bluetooth pairing more bass and more
compact design that gives you a nice
noise isolating fit ray cons wireless
earbuds are incredibly comfortable
they're perfect for on-the-go listening
as well as for taking phone calls pick
up a pair see what the hype is all about
I use ray cons routinely they're
excellent my wife has ray cons as well
get 15% off your order at buy rakin comm
slash Ben that is Bui are a YCL n comm /
Ben by Rick on comm / Ben for 15% off
recon wireless earbuds by rakin comm /
Ben go check them out right now ok so as
I say the battle over what to do with
Bernie now is breaking out into the open
in the Democratic Party James Carville
who who's honestly his input into the
Democratic primaries was pretty
invaluable for helping boost Joe Biden
he kept saying like if we nominate
Bernie we're gonna get slaughtered here
guys
and people took him fairly seriously
well now James Carville is saying let's
shut this puppy down this thing is over
why are we allowing Bernie onstage some
more we got to acknowledge that he
created a movement he did some some
truly remarkable things in American
politics and certainly Vice President
Biden's we've got to talk to him and
discuss this but we also the camp we
can't just these Democratic voters who
just coming out in every corner of this
country saying let's get on with this
thing now our mission as a party is to
defeat Donald Trump
according to 538 there's a 99 or 1
chance that that Vice President Biden is
gonna be a nominee let's shut this puppy
down and let's move on and worry about
November this thing is decided there's
no reason to keep it going it but not
even a day longer ok so he's saying no
more debates no more primaries let's
just be done with this thing it's it's
done we are finished and he's right
statistically speaking I mean Carville
can read the data as well as anybody can
hey Bernie's done bernie is toast bernie
is a shriveled piece of red debris I
mean he is he's finished he's going back
to his pudding cups
he's going back to his lake house and
that's it ok but that does not mean that
he can't make trouble from the outside
Jim's clobberin I'm trying to do the
same thing again this does give the
sense inside the Democratic Party that
the Democratic Party elite that the
heads of the Democratic Party are trying
to shut down Bernie which of course is
exactly the exactly the message that
Bernie wishes to promote
I mean what Bernie would love more than
anything else is to spend the next two
months fulminating about how the
Democratic Party shut the door on him
the minute that they got the opportunity
they barely open the door wide enough to
let him through and then the minute he
stuck his foot in they proceeded to cut
off his toes old mythical Cinderella
style by the way little-known facts
about the Cinderella myth originally the
stepsisters cut off their toes to try
and fit their feet inside the glass
slippers just weird things he didn't
know
in any case james Clyburn who is the
chief sponsor of joe biden's victory in
south carolina his late stage
endorsement was very important to Biden
clapeyron said there shouldn't be any
more debates we're done here I think we
will be at a point where Joe Biden will
be the prohibitive nominee of the party
and I think the DNC the Democratic
National Committee
she then stepped in make an assessment
and determine whether or not they'll
have any more debate ok so again this
this does look like the Biden team
attempting to shut down all future
possibilities for Bernie Sanders for
Bernie re-entering the debate which
could theoretically be the worst move
Van Jones on CNN he was saying listen
this is a mistake Biden needs to reach
out to Bernie somehow now the problem is
there isn't a great way to reach out for
the for the for the craggy old annoying
communists like what exactly did you do
to bring that guy inside the tent here's
Van Jones saying the body needs to do
more but again how do you negotiate with
with a political militant like Bernie
Sanders they thought that they were
going to be able to surround the divided
establishment with their movement
crushed that divided establishment and
move forward instead the establishment
United and stopped them now what do you
do last time
Bernie Sanders got beaten there was an
assumption that all his people were just
gonna fall in line and vote against
Trump and there was not enough care for
the concern and the pain of his base I
think tonight there's gonna be a lot of
crowing a lot of relief on the part of
the establishment but keep it temperate
and turn turn to those people and say we
want to be your champion don't do that
you're gonna have a Pyrrhic victory okay
so so joe biden did do that i don't
think that it's gonna be enough i mean
if you have ever talked to people who
are like big bernie sanders fans they
despise the democratic establishment
they despise joe biden I mean they hated
Peabody judges if ever Buddha judge was
too much of a sellout what do you think
they think of Joe Biden
eighty year old lifelong Democrat whose
great accomplishments have included
naming train stations after himself on
Amtrak and well what what do you think
that they think about that guy what do
you think they think about the guy who
was taking institutional Democratic
money what do you think they think about
a guy every relative of who's has
actually been involved in some or other
form of corruption I don't think those
people come back inside the tent and
that is the largest institutional
obstacle to Joe Biden becoming president
of the United States so that is where
things stand now again Joe Biden's basic
pitch and he was throwing it out there
yesterday is that Joe Biden was going to
be a solidifying figure in American
politics that has been his pitch there's
a problem with that too which is that
Joe Biden is not himself particularly
solid as I say the fact that he is
nearly comatose is probably his best
asset I've been saying this really since
he declared but the fact that he's
almost a dead person almost literally
that that is actually a good thing for
him because it makes people feel that he
is not threatening to them he's not
gonna leap off that deathbed and
suddenly club you over the head with
medicare-for-all that's not something
that Joe Biden is capable of doing but
in a campaign the notion that he is some
sort of real return to grace that is an
overstatement by the media and I think
people are gonna find that out really
quickly Donald Trump does have a few
lines of attack on Joe Biden it that he
has yet to lose one is obviously the
corruption he did go after Joe Biden on
the hunter Biden stuff there's a report
yesterday that James Biden who is Joe's
brother is now in trouble over basically
going to some sort of health from and
suggesting to them that his brother was
going to sponsor government regulation
that would help the company and they
proceeded to built the firm of hundreds
of thousands of dollars we know that
some of his other brothers have been
involved in some stuff like that
something was Frank who was involved in
some corrupt activity or alleged corrupt
activity down in Florida so that is one
line of attack that you can expect from
President Trump obviously are gonna see
President Trump hit sleepy Joe for being
again on the verge of senility but the
the third line of attack is that Joe
Biden isn't himself that stable so Joe
Biden has been perceived as a more
stable quantity than Donald Trump
because pretty much everybody has
perceived as a more stable quantity than
Donald Trump
but when Joe Biden makes the pitch that
he is sort of the savior of American
grace it's a weird pitch it's a very
weird pitch we're gonna get to that in
just one second first let's talk about
the
fact that you may have employees who are
not exactly what you need let's say for
example that you had an employee let's
call him Michael moles and let's say
this employee was always on the bubble
like this person was pretty much useless
when you hired him and so you decided
okay well let's try him in a talent role
and then he proved himself to be
slightly less useless in the talent role
and then let's say that he went to a
conference was called CPAC where he
proceeded to hobnob with a bunch of
people and it turns out that somebody at
CPAC had coronavirus and then instead of
self-quarantine this let's say this
person just strolled on into the office
was taking off his shirt throwing his
skin cells everywhere to let's head he's
just hacking hacking up a lung and let's
say that he was on the verge of
basically poisoning everybody in your
office with coronavirus would you keep
this person around would you well if you
were looking for a placement for Michael
moles which I have been for years but I
haven't tried it yet maybe I should try
zip recruiter dot-com if you need to
find the best candidate for your growing
business zip recruiters you're smart
efficient hiring solution from
healthcare manufacturing to professional
and business services zipper crew makes
hiring great people faster and easier as
well today you can try zip recruiter for
free at zip recruiter comm slash daily
wear when you go to zip recruiter with
one-click you send your job to zip
recruiters network of over 100 leading
job sites what happens next
zip recruiter finds the best matches for
your job and then invites them to apply
it's so effective that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter do
get a quality candidate within the very
first day so I am certainly going to
list in Michael moles as a derelict
useless human being and we are going to
replace him using zip recruiter comm we
can try zip recruit for free when we go
to zip recruiters comm slash daily wire
that is zip recruiters calm / Dai ly WI
re zip recruiter comm / daily wire zip
recruiter is indeed the smartest way to
hire the good news for Michael is that
may be out there there's somebody
looking for a janitor and using
super-awkward comm / it daily wire and
Michael is eminently qualified for that
job so you should go check out zip
recruiter calm / daily wire alrighty so
as i say joe biden's final pitch really
is that he has a return to character
this is what he's been picked this was
his opening at it is now his closing out
here is Joe Biden
making that pitch last night everything
that has made America American is truly
at stake I believe this nation can
overcome four years of Donald Trump and
given eight
four more years and forever and
fundamentally changed the very character
this nation we can't let that happen but
winning means but winning means uniting
America not sowing more division and
anger okay so this is his there's
only one problem Joe Biden is not a good
messenger for this he is not a
good messenger for it this like
yesterday he was in Michigan he was
campaigning and a bunch of hard hats in
Michigan walk up to him and started
asking about his gun policy now Joe
Biden is a gun grabber I mean we have
proof that he's a gun grab her Joe Biden
in this exchange proceeds to threaten to
kick somebody's ass threatens to take it
outside suggest that somebody's being a
horse's ass and then also lies about his
gun record now I know there are a lot of
people on the right who are like well
you know how could you buy an act like
this okay guys let's be real Donald
Trump is president okay so can we spare
me with the pearl clutching the Pearl
clutching isn't the thing the things
that Biden lies about his record
consistently but also it does undercut
Joe Biden's I am a statesman routine
when he is not in fact all that
statesmen like he has been kind of a a
slightly kooky uncle figure for for
quite a while
here is Joe Biden being a slightly kooky
uncle figure who gets drunk at the
family picnic and then threatens to
fight you after you say that the Yankees
are overrated this year
[Music]
this Joe Biden is yelling things that
don't even make sense the guy's saying
an ar-15 is not machine gun in Joe bands
like yes it is yes it is guys like well
no it's not it so do you need a hundred
rounds completely different argument
okay then he says you don't need an AR
14 which is not a gun and then he
suggests don't be a horse's ass in a
armed is a machine gun I'm not working
for you you're full of bleep
he tells the guy to shush that's your
model of stability Democrats like really
that's the guy who is your model of
stability also it happens to be that
he's lying about his own record on guns
the guy comes forward he says you're
gonna grab our guns and bands like I
would never grab your guns I love the
Second Amendment okay let's just
remember Joe Biden who's gonna put full
on
[Applause]
okay that was five minutes ago also Joe
Biden was straight up asked whether he
would take people's guns and his answer
was bingo malarkey Mudd said yeah
blackjack and right to gun owners out
there who say well a by an
administration means they're gonna come
for my gun bingo you're right if you
have an assault weapon the fact of the
matter is they should be illegal
period look the Second Amendment doesn't
say you can't restrict the kinds of
weapons people can on bingo bango jack
bingo bomb Oh malarkey matte black jack
hey this is this is your captain of
stability and also a person who is
indeed lying about his own record which
is something that Biden is done
routinely he's I don't know whether he
actually knows he's lying or whether he
just thinks he's telling the truth I
really don't know which is a great
quality in a politician seriously when
they don't even know whether that along
it's a fantastic quality I remember when
Joe Biden was debating Paul Ryan and the
Vice
initial debate back in 2012 and Joe
Biden just said in the middle of the
debate that Lebanon had kicked Iran out
of out of the country and I just
remember thinking is that thing that
happened like I don't remember any of
that happening and Ryan I think also had
the reaction like I'm pretty sure that
didn't happen but I can't call him on it
because maybe I'm wrong
but the fact is that Joe Biden does have
an unusual facility to say things that
are not true with a straight face mainly
because I'm not sure that he knows
they're not true is but but bottom line
is that Joe Biden if the if the image of
him is a font of rationality and
foundational stability in a time of
volatility I'm not sure dizzier guy I
mean five minutes ago he was saying to
people he was calling people fat on the
campaign trail calling him a damn liar
this was like two months ago two months
ago she said I'm George Strait Jack
you don't hear that man MSNBC you did
not hear that all what you heard look
okay I'm not gonna get a hard look fat
look here's the that's that's the guy
who you're running up there as a return
to American civility that guy as I've
said a thousand times Donald Trump is
not a difference in kind
he's just a difference in tenor that's
all okay Donald Trump is not radically
different from Joe Biden in any
appreciable way in terms of his
attitudes or in terms of the language
uses it's just he does more of it
so if Joe Biden is a return to normalcy
the normalcy ain't that great and I
think there are a lot of people who are
about to find that out okay in a second
we're gonna give you all the coronavirus
updates continues to be scary we'll give
you all the updates on what is going on
with it in just one second first let's
talk about the reality of running a
business one of your bigger cost is
gonna be HR okay HR is a serious issue
and if you have compliance issues if you
have liability issues HR can be a
nightmare but you don't have the money
to go out and hire somebody for 80 grand
a year to run HR for you I mean to
handle the wrongful termination suits
minimum wage requirements labor
regulations instead go check out Bambi
it's about be a.m. be EE it was created
specifically for small business you can
get a dedicated HR manager and craft HR
policy and maintain your compliance all
for just 99 bucks a month with Bambi you
can change a are from your biggest
liability to your biggest strength
you're dedicated to HR managers
available by phone email or real-time
chat they craft a policy just for you
it's not somebody overseas it's somebody
in the United States helping you handle
your HR from onboarding determinations
they customize your policies to fit your
business and help you manage your
employees day to day for 99 bucks a
month we here at daily wire
we have an entire HR department but you
can't afford an entire HR department but
you need the same level of compliance go
check out Bambi comm slash Shapiro right
now month to month no hidden fees cancel
anytime
go to Bambi comm slash apparel right now
to schedule your free HR audit that is
Bambi calm slash a Pierrot spell BAM to
the B EE BAM be calm slash apparel be a
mba.com slash Schapiro go save yourself
some time save yourself some money and
really insulate yourself from liability
right now for a small business looking
for HR Bambi is the best to check out
Bambi comm slash Shapiro now we're gonna
get to coronavirus all the updates which
are coming in Fast and Furious Plus
Harvey Weinstein has now been sentenced
to 23 years in prison we'll get to that
too but first time is running out to get
25 percent off all daily wire
memberships with coupon code never
socialist so hurry before the DIA lens
just like Bernie Sanders's campaign
we've been a fond farewell to Bernie
Sanders in his campaign and Soviet
national anthem daily wire members get
an ad-free website experience access to
all of our live broadcasts in show
library the full three hours of the ben
shapiro show access to the mailbag and
now exclusive election insight op-eds
from yours truly
daily wire members also get to ask us
questions during backstage I know all
access to allows you to join in live
online Q&A is with me and the other
hosts along with all of this of course
yet the magnificent irreplaceable the
singular leftist yours tumbler if you
haven't already download the daily water
apps you can get all of our great
content on the go again that is 25% off
on daily wire memberships for all plans
using coupon code never socialist so
head on over to Taylor wire.com slash
subscribe this would be the last week we
will be giving you this magnificent
offer so act now before you read it that
is daily wire calm slash subscribe you
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
well in coronavirus news the British
health minister and conservative member
of powerful Parliament Nadine at dories
has been diagnosed with coronavirus now
so the Health Minister of Great Britain
has coronavirus miss Tory says she's
been self isolating at home Labour MP
Rachel Maskell said she has been told to
do the same as she had met miss stories
the Department of Health in Britain said
Miss Tories first showed symptoms on
Thursday the same day she attended an
event hosted by the Prime Minister
right now UK had a documented total of
382 cases as of yesterday six people
with the virus have died in the UK in
the United States the total number of
cases now has surpassed 1000 cases in
the United States we have 29 deaths so
far the the clusters are happening on
the coasts mainly in Massachusetts New
York Santa Clara California and up in
Seattle Washington
the first known u.s. coronavirus case
was announced January 21st in Washington
State the pace of diagnosis has
quickened significantly in recent weeks
at the start of the month 70 cases had
been reported in this country most of
them tied to overseas travel since then
new cases have been pouring in by the
dozens and then by the hundreds the
corona virus updates are coming fast and
furious the mayor of New York Bill de
Blasio he said that there are lots of
cases coming in like dozens per day in
New York City as testing is made
available it is obvious that there are a
lot of people who are at least carrying
coronavirus without knowing that they
are carrying corona virus the the German
public has now been warned that up to 70
percent of Germans face the possibility
of infection that's according to Angela
Merkel and of course the top US health
official souther dr. Anthony foutch II
he said this is going to get worse so
doctor foul she said all hands are
basically on deck with this thing these
are really simple
keeping the workplace safe keeping the
home safe keeping the schools safe and
keeping commercial establishing safe
this should be universal for the country
everyone should be doing that whether
you live in a zone that has community
spread or not when you have community
spread you obviously going to ratchet up
the kinds of mitigations that you have
but at a minimum this is the minimum
that we should be doing so everybody
should say all hands on deck this is
what we need to do in non shocking news
thanks to again the up and down of the
coronavirus news the stock market is
getting creamed
today is just up and down insanely it
was up like a thousand points yesterday
and then it has dumped again back down a
thousand points below twenty four
thousand in early morning trading pretty
amazing how the stock market is bouncing
around like a yo-yo now we're not going
to know honestly where anything stands
until the end of April Megan McArdle has
an interesting column over at the
Washington Post a lot of people write
really like everyone is looking around
going I don't see a lot of coronavirus
out there we've had a grand total of
like four thousand deaths worldwide if
you look at the flu every year it kills
like a hundred thousand people worldwide
minimum maybe hundreds of thousands of
people worldwide every year so why are
we all so worried about coronavirus well
Megan McArdle has this statistical
thought experiment to remind you that
when there's an exponential growth
factor things move really quickly right
you don't see anything and then you see
everything right let's say that you have
a pond with lily pads this is the
example that you give statistically and
it explains why we're all so worried
today if you have a pond with lily pads
and the lily pads are going to overtake
the pond as they grow and each day the
lily pads double right the number of
lily pads double so let's say that day
one it's one two it's two day three it's
four right so it keeps doubling on the
very last day the lily pads covered the
entire pond the question is at what
point did lily pads cover half the pond
right at what point did lily pads cover
half the pond and the answer is the day
before they covered the entire pond Rex
if they're doubling every day then that
means that half the pond was covered
yesterday and today boom suddenly the
entire pond is covered that is how
exponential growth works okay that is
what people are fearing in terms of
coronavirus is that when you have
exponential growth of coronavirus what
you end up with is no one around me has
it oops
everyone around me that's it right that
that that is what people are fearing is
that sudden is that sudden uptick and
this is what is being feared by the
Trump former Homeland Security Advisor
Tom Bossert he says hospitals are
basically 10 days away from being
creamed he suggested in an op-ed that we
are we are in trouble in terms of our
hospital facilities he says officials
must pull the trigger on aggressive
interventions you said aggressive
interventions put off and ease the peak
burden on hospitals and other health
care infrastructure and that of course
is true as coronavirus swells then the
hospitals need to be prepared as I
already said Mayor Bill DeBlasio has
said that things are happening intensely
in New York City and governor jay Inslee
has now restricted gatherings more than
250 people in King
as well as several as well as Snohomish
and Pierce counties which are the
biggest counties in Washington State
that means no soccer games
it means no it means no baseball games
it means that basically all major
gatherings ought to be canceled
according to jay Inslee the governor of
Washington state's doctor foul Chee has
suggested there be no crowds at NBA
games so basically if you have tickets
for opening day in the United States for
baseball
you can fairly Bank that that is not
going to happen a lot of colleges are
canceling events I would not be
surprised if my college events this
semester for example are canceled that
would not be a great shock again I think
that all of this makes a certain amount
of sense like better caution then to
have this viral outbreak you want to
reduce these the spread and then the
quickness of the spread to give us time
right now we're bargaining for time
right we don't know what the death rates
are on this thing we just don't and what
that means is that every attempt to slow
the spread of the virus buys a day for
people to develop vaccines that are
going to be more effective in slowing or
stopping the spread of the virus so it
becomes just another seasonal problem
instead of becoming an overwhelming
threat to Western populations so this it
is in this light that is important to
recognize that when the federal
government fails along this along these
lines it can be absolutely disastrous
there's a piece from The New York Times
that is just devastating talking about
how the federal government did in fact
blow the month the president Trump
bought so President Trump said very
early on we're shutting down travel from
China and a lot of people on left like
oh this is racist oh this is terrible
same people were saying Wu hen virus mu
hen virus is racist he can't say woo Han
virus mr. Trump said no we're shutting
down travel that was a very good thing
it was a very smart thing it was the
right thing to do the problem is that
only buys you time because it turns out
that some people are going to get in and
then you got a problem so what did the
federal government do with the month the
president front bought them by shutting
down travel from from Wuhan the answer
is basically nothing according to dr.
Helen Chu infectious disease expert in
Seattle she knew the United States did
not have much time in late January the
first confirmed American case of corona
virus had landed in her area critical
questions needed answers had the man
infected anyone else according to the
New York Times was the deadly virus
already lurking in other communities and
spreading as luck would have it dr. chu
had a way to monitor the region for
months as part of a reach research
project into the flu she and a team of
researchers had been collecting nasal
swabs from residents experiencing
symptoms throughout the Puget Sound
region to repurpose the test for monitor
and coronavirus they would need the
support of state and federal officials
but nearly everywhere dr. chu turned
officials repeatedly rejected the idea
interviews and emails show even as weeks
crawled by and outbreaks emerged in
countries outside of China where the
infection began by February 25th
dr. chu and her colleagues could not
bear to wait any longer they began
performing coronavirus tests without
government approval well came back
confirmed their worst fear they quickly
had a positive test from a local
teenager with no recent travel history
the corona virus had already established
itself on American soil without anybody
realizing it dr. chu recalled thinking
it must have in here this entire time
it's just everywhere already in fact
officials would later discover through
testing the virus had already
contributed to the deaths of two people
it would go on to kill 20 more in the
Seattle region over the following days
federal and state officials said the flu
study could not be repurposed because it
didn't have explicit permission from
research subjects the labs were also not
certified for clinical work while
acknowledging the ethical questions dr.
chu and others argued there should be
more flexibility in an emergency during
which so many lives could be lost this
is correct I mean like if you give
permission for somebody to do a nasal
swab for flu and then that is repurposed
a nasal swab for corona virus I honestly
failed to see how any reasonable person
would consider that a violation of
privacy like oh nobody must know that I
had corona batten like they're not gonna
release your specific corona virus tests
it just allows the state to do something
on Monday night state regulators told
them to stop testing altogether
the failure to tap into the flu study
detailed here for the first time was
just one in a series of missed chances
by the federal government to ensure more
widespread testing during the early days
of the outbreak when containment would
have been easier instead local officials
across the country were left to work in
the dark as the crisis grew undetected
and exponentially now do I think this is
Trump's fault no I don't I don't think
Trump is monitoring local level tests I
think this is the fault of a massive
regulatory bureaucracy that prevents
people from doing reasonable things it
turns out that the federal government
while it is well-placed to issue
broad national guidelines is not well
placed to deal with local testing that
has to be done it turns out the local
communities may be the fastest to react
to this sort of thing right voluntary
shutdowns right now are happening across
the country with regard to major public
events and those are happening on the
local and state level without the
federal government
even doing anything it turns out that
people who see federalism is the
obstacle to this sort of thing they're
doing it wrong
local and state officials are more
answerable to local populations and are
in fact more likely to request the
people do responsible things I mean the
fact is that poram was yesterday in the
in the Jewish community basically every
poram sudha that I heard of in my area I
mean every big poor meal with big
gatherings lots of kids those were
basically shut down voluntarily without
any guidance from the federal state or
local officials okay so so the notion
that the federal government needs to be
running this thing in extraordinarily
top-down fashion the federal government
needs to be coordinating all the
officials letting them know sort of the
minimum of what they expect but standing
in the way of local officials doing what
they need to do to tamp this thing down
is a completely different thing and that
is a testament to the stupidity of
bureaucracy generally it is just a very
very light shadow of what happened in
China in the very early stages where
China was literally imprisoning people
talking about this stuff when you have
the CDC saying to people you can't
repurpose that flu testing kit in order
to test for a corona virus because you
may violate federal protocols just
demonstrates the idiocy of having a
bureaucracy this large and this
ridiculous doesn't mean we don't need
federal staffers we do but having a
bureaucratic thicket like this that is
unable impenetrable that that is a big
mistake dr. Robert Redfield director of
the CDC said in an interview on Friday
that acting quickly was critical for
combating an outbreak he said Time
Matters
he said there's still time to be back
coronavirus in the United States had
said it's gonna take rigorous aggressive
Public Health what I like to say block
and tackle
block and tackle it means if you find a
new case you isolated but the question
is how exactly are gonna isolate it when
testing kits are not available widely
only about 8,500 specimens or nose swabs
have been taken at all since the
beginning of the outbreak a figure that
is almost certainly larger than the
number of people tested since one person
can have multiple swabs by comparison
South Korea which discovered its first
test case around the same time as the US
has reported having the capacity to test
10,000 people a day since late February
that is indeed a failure of the federal
government that's not mean again that
it's Trump's fault it does mean that the
response here by the CDC was absolutely
insufficient in the early days the
agency released criteria for deciding
which individuals should be tested for
the virus at first they said only those
who had a fever and respiratory issues
and had
from the outbreaks origin in Wuhan the
criteria were so strict that a sick man
in Seattle had visited Wu hen did not
even meet it still worried state health
officials pushed him to get a check and
finally the CDC agreed and then his
results came back positive around this
time the Washington State Department of
Health began discussions with the
Seattle flu study there was a hitch the
flu project primarily used research labs
non clinical ones its coronavirus test
was not approved by the FDA so the group
was not certified to provide test
results to anyone outside their own
investigators Scott McDowell a former
CDC official current deputy director at
the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
asked for help from leaders of the CDC's
coronavirus response later dr. Lynn
quest the state epidemiologist in
Washington wrote an email to dr. Alicia
fry the chief of the CDC's epidemiology
and prevention branch requesting the
study be used to test for corona virus
CDC repeatedly said not possible they
said you have to check with the FDA
so instead CDC kicked it over to the FDA
the FDA could not offer the approval
because the lab was not certified and so
none of the tests actually get done the
answer to this is obviously Medicare for
all and a massive federal bureaucracy
running this thing from top down
obviously that is the answer to all of
this that was an argument by the way you
heard in the immediate aftermath of the
outbreak was that we need more federal
intervention ISM okay two things can be
drilled ones you need more effective
federal intervention and also if you are
talking about layers upon layers of
bureaucracy making things better wrong
go wrong go so this is where things
stand at current this sort of
uncertainty means that it's going to set
us back a while it means that we are not
going to have clear information on
exactly the extent of coronavirus and
again we are starting to see isolated
cases it does affect mainly elderly
people their nursing home industry is
basically advised if you have a parent
in a nursing home to not go visit them
right now not because they're going to
infect you but because you might
unknowingly infect them and then it'll
run like wildfire throughout the entire
nursing home that's what happened in
Kirkland Washington it's also impacting
small clusters of younger more healthy
people there was a man named mark Tybalt
who was one of the first American side
notes with the novel coronavirus and
apparently he ended up in the ICU at
Providence Hospital fighting the illness
that attacked his lungs he says I was
one inch from death no doubt about it
roughly 80% of kovat 19 cases tend to be
mild or moderate more than 60
thousand people globally have recovered
older people those with underlying
health conditions are at a higher risk
this guy had asthma that is his only
underlying health condition with that
said you know we just don't know where
this thing is going at this point and
that's why caution is necessary it's
good that the Bernie and and Biden
campaigns canceled their rallies that is
a smart thing to do also the attempts to
to push bailouts at this point the kind
of bailouts that are being talked about
the federal government has never seen an
opportunity for a bailout it didn't take
but the bailouts they're talking about
are largely going to be ineffective
right now we are in a watch and wait
time when everybody needs to exercise
caution we should be using social
distancing if you don't have to go to a
large gathering you probably should not
go to a large gathering you know all at
least for a couple of weeks now this is
the important thing to remember in all
this there is a timeline here because
this is not indefinite we're not talking
about a year from now you're not gonna
be able to go to a baseball game or a
basketball game three months from now
you're probably fine to go to a baseball
game or a basketball game trying to tamp
this thing down within three months of
its outbreak when they've now seen
declining diagnosis same thing in South
Korea but the faster we take measures to
protect ourselves the faster this thing
is going to peter out that would be the
goal here so that's important so Netflix
and Show might be the answer to some of
our problems here so subscribe to The
Daily wire and watch all the old
episodes is basically one of the answers
there already time for a thing I like
and then a couple of things that I hate
so things that I like today I myself
have been reading science fiction late
into the evenings this is because when
you have a small child who's crying
throughout the night what exactly are
you going to do when you are the husband
and my wife is busy and she can feed the
child I cannot so this means I just keep
her company and I read sci-fi so I've
been reading Isaac rereading Isaac
Asimov's foundation novels they are
fantastic
Asimov's foundation novels really sort
of changed the sci-fi world they do
illustrate the difference between sci-fi
and fantasy the basic difference between
sci-fi and fantasy actually Asimov
there's a really kind of cool short
story filled little sci-fi magazine that
comes out every couple of months with
major writers writing for it it's called
Asimov and there's an essay at the
beginning of last month's Asimov
Magazine talking about the difference
between sci-fi and fantasy because
sometimes it's hard to tell the
difference and the basic difference is
that there are predictable rules in the
sci-fi world that are not broken by deus
ex machina well that that is a smile two
universes right ESMA universes are
filled with these sort of predictable
rules you establish the rules
then you live by the rules he's a really
creative thinker the foundation novels
are of course classics of the genre and
they the original foundation novel is
just fantastic
I'm not gonna spoil it for you if you've
never read it you should go check it out
it is appropriate for all ages
effectively it is great go check it out
Isaac as most of the foundation novels
and you start with foundation then you
move on to second foundation there's
Foundation and Empire and there's a
bunch of them but the first three
particularly are pretty good okay time
for some things that I hate so the the
person hardest hit by Bernie Sanders
falling flat on his face and the
primaries last night was the the
irrepressible AOC so AOC went on her
Instagram and lamented Bernie Sanders is
lost last night she is more conciliatory
with the Democratic Party infrastructure
than many people thought she would be
I'm not particularly shocked by that
AOC does not want to be alienated from
all the halls of power she's been smart
enough to sort of push until she met
resistance from Nancy Pelosi and then
back off this led David Axelrod to label
ALC a pragmatic figure inside the
Democratic Party which is truths as far
as it goes the problem is is that AO
sees pragmatism is really about the lack
of pragmatism by the Democratic Party
the Democratic Party is apparently
totally willing to go along with
socialism if they have to and they have
they have really seated far too much
ground to Bernie he's gonna come back to
bite them they seated far too much
ground to AOC so yeah she looks
pragmatic in the sense that she is not
running screaming away from the
Democratic Party the problem for the
Democrats is they should be running
screaming away from aoc here's Axelrod
labeling her pragmatic which really is
to suggest the Democratic Party is
itself not pragmatic let me suggest that
I think that one person who may be
important in this process is AOC she she
has emerged as a really important figure
among these young Americans who are
yearning for real serious solutions to
these problems and yet she's shown
herself to be a very pragmatic yet
principled we figure okay now here's the
problem the minute that she actually
comes to grips with Joe Biden the minute
she starts campaigning for Joe Biden
if Bernie sits this one out then she
becomes the outlier burning is still the
leader of this movement not a OC aoc may
drive crowds but she does not have a
coherent constituency in the same way
that Bernie sander
does aoc last night she got on that
Instagram and she was lamenting about it
she said there's no sugarcoating it it's
a tough night and then she suggested she
congratulated Biden on his winch said if
you win a race you win a race which is a
lot more conciliatory then then Sanders
is going to be obviously she said older
voters which we know are more reliable
voters which we know turnout have
decisively gone to Vice President Biden
she said there's a generational divide
within the Democratic Party on health
care on climate change on foreign policy
pretty much every policy imaginable as a
younger person in this movement I take a
lot of that information for how we
navigate the next decade so she's
basically saying okay guys hold off
support Biden for now we'll be back AOC
definitely wants to run for president in
just a few years she is not denying that
okay that that is why she is practical
with that said Bernie could provide a
problem for AOC now does any of this
mean that AOC is actually in her right
mind when it comes to politics of course
not of course not
for example here was AOC last night
talking about how it was racist because
people were not eating as much at
Chinese restaurants again I've not seen
the evidence that people are not going
to Chinese restaurants but AOC suggests
that there's widespread anti-asian
racism breaking out all over the United
States this is your pragmatic Democratic
politician aoc honestly it sounds almost
so silly to say but there's a lot of
restaurants that are feeling the pain of
racism where people are literally not
patronage I nice restaurants they're not
patron occasion restaurants because of
just straight-up racism around the
coronavirus they're not patron ting them
I mean you you mean you do have to worry
about people painting other people
patronizing like right now I'm
patronizing her I'm being very
patronizing torneo see yes it has dual
meanings secondary definitions okay so
if that is your that is your practical
Democratic politician aoc by the way a
lot of businesses are struggling right
now over legitimate concerns
okay Chinese restaurants have been
reporting a drop in business that is
true it is also true that a lot of
restaurants are reporting a drop in
business you know why there are a lot of
hard surfaces at restaurants there's an
entire article in The New York Times
yesterday about what you should do
during the corona virus outbreak with
regard to going to restaurants one of
their answers if you want to order order
out because if you're actually at a
restaurant and you are presumably
sitting at a table a table is a hard
surface the hard surface has been
patronized by has
by other people who've been putting
their hands all over that if you have to
go sign then use a pen use your finger
and then immediately use hand sanitizer
because lots of hands all over lots of
things at a restaurant okay so this is
not about people being like the Chinese
restaurant probably somebody has Wu Han
virus there that's not like that this
entire overblown idea that people are
super racist about it let that we are in
the midst of a second Japanese
internment in the United States none of
that is true like well where's the
evidence for this the media are so
focused on this sort of stuff in every
instance it's incredible in the
aftermath of 9/11 there is all this talk
about a widespread upsurge in
anti-muslim violence the statistics did
not bear that out now we are getting all
of these rumors of anti Asian behavior
all over the United States and that is
really not borne out by statistical by
statistical proof what's happening
generally is that people are making I
would say that is it possible there are
some people who are who are wondering
whether people have traveled to
epicenters of coronavirus recently and
then are more worried about that and
they're using group data to make those
decisions I mean that's possible is that
racist it's not really racist that's
just using sort of best available
information it's the difference between
what tom is so called discrimination
type 1 and discrimination type to
discrimination type 1 is you are a bad
person because you have a particular
race discrimination type 2 is basically
I'm going to use the best available data
at hand right now is there a better shot
that you've traveled to Wu hen than
somebody who's standing right next to
you if the answer is yes I'm gonna be a
little bit more risk-averse with regard
to all of that now maybe that's what
people are using that does not mean
anti-chinese racism that does not mean
that people are racist against Chinese
people are racist against Asian people
or anything like that but this is your
reasonable voice inside the Democratic
Party good luck to the future of the
Democratic Party Bernie Sanders may be
gone but his spirit lives on in the nuts
in the squad who continue to be nuts and
are not going anywhere
alrighty we'll be back here a little bit
later today two additional hours of
content otherwise we'll be back here
tomorrow make sure that you subscribe
and use never socialist as our code
right now and you will get 25% off that
is ending shortly so go check that out
we're at large well you know what we are
i'm ben shapiro this is the bench bureau
show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
I douse key technical producer Austin
Stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SCI events audio
is mixed by Mike Cora Mina hair and
makeup is by Anika Geneva the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]